[Music]
whoa this week we've got metal yoga
young Museum and to kill a clown take it
away
kiss bunny I saw my neck on the coolest
how about the suicide with the boobs
first sorry there is this heavy metal
yoga classes you can work and I know new
your complete opposite oh mama
it's a video it's crazy here we go oh
[ __ ] I just look like devil worship I
think just such as you might do it on a
lot of how about yoga practice because
you can you will need has gone forth
emotions like a come up or children to
meetings for the poses like today the
sake of bows or the destroyer bows and
the stage-diving clothes and like I try
to make it more fun and rename it and
make it more matter and corns up and
then with your breath last time to stage
dive it forward that's right that's
pretty creative making a more relatable
don't stick your thought out I want your
butt to be drawn besides during regular
yoga poses also do a lot of other stuff
that's just fun like I do mosh pits or
circle pits and yoga classes or the
everyone has a chance to do things that
they wanted to do in front of the stage
yeah
absolutely on yoga that's like a really
interesting take on yoga yeah so
opposite it just has to be calm serene
because Yoga is the post made it a
spiritual experience isn't it like
originally it's a spiritual thing and
then it just became a form of exercise
now as people see it so I wonder if like
those like hardcore would he call them
Yogi's yogi even like that's not how you
do it I think I'm still a spiritual
experience
now she's tying it with lightning metal
and like aggression and getting that out
of your system she yeah it has like
devil-worshiping tucán she'll say things
like we raise our voices to stay tuned
with a deep dark howl things like oh god
so the creator of this yoga's class name
is Saskia and she's a german-born jamun
she created this class because it's very
her I could see that feeling good
head-banging Buddhism like you're just
meditating your life like that yes soon
as you came up with the idea when she
was learning or she was but a long time
Doorly Zoo Yoga to become a yoga teacher
yoga instructor and so at home and she
would practice you put on metal because
that's like that's her thing that's what
she loved that was just her so she when
she was thinking about it like well when
I create my own classes like what kind
of music kind of plans you're there but
what's the most me thing to do and I
play heavy metals I always thought it
was funny that people needed crazy mess
I mean on Oh people need it like crazy
like motivating rock or aggressive music
to lift because since I already have
aggression inside of me I have I need
something calm to kind of balance it out
because when it's like I'm all like
lifting and I'll man I don't even need
this to like go hard with it it's very
counterintuitive for me because of maybe
the way go
the is exploded Express to me from the
people who have told me I should try
yoga or people who are already like this
and they want to do the opposite of it
that's me yeah so versus I need to calm
down I think more especially in the from
the yoga is from being able to scream
yeah right so I think it's confusing you
know
so I've clearly agree with this again
you get to come you get the screen you
get to yell get to do all this crazy
stuff so that's the part that people
gain stress relief from not from you
holding a pose and trying to find inner
peace because the inner peace is Dimity
I'm not going to be doing that [ __ ] do
it deep down growl to know our school
Doraemon see Cheryl it's fine
next article I find next story the
Museum of ice cream has not opened hmm
I didn't even know there was an official
museum for that mom if you get to taste
ice cream technically is not really a
museum before like an art exhibit but
fun [ __ ] life sounds like my jam
though they opened it in New York last
year that's a long that looks so cool
yeah so they'll it was only open for a
limited time and it immediately sold out
once it was announced how we make that
[ __ ] this way yeah I hate every life
there's no real ice cream it's not
Museum of ice cream I'll know the
history of ice cream on a few and
spending it exactly so they [ __ ] lie
to me cook bake I like it said I know I
mean I love ice cream I want to go in
there and be like you're just dirt
talking ice cream yeah I want to go
through the ages like a timeline like
you walk in and they're like in Egypt
there was a cow in the milk the cow they
they freeze this yes you know and then
like whatever and then this is ice cream
and then fast-forward now you're like in
the Renaissance when was ice invented
now laughter you know like in Egypt how
do they freeze it they probably [ __ ]
squirted the [ __ ] cow milk out and
they they went to the the Persian market
and they collab with people there were
all the trades go I'll give you my
daughter if you give me a bowl of ice it
took that home and then made ice cream
think I got confused too there's a
museum exactly Museum reminds me of
history I'm not sure if it's in Italy if
that's what it's supposed to be okay our
talent
but it's called the Museum of ice I know
that's the name of it but it's more like
an art gallery I want someone to take me
through time and see my dreams
throughout the salivation thank you I
want to see like ever ham Lincoln like
licking on the [ __ ] vanilla cone
you know and then be like oh you know
and in like five you know how they got
fun facts and they go Benjamin Franklin
if they was [ __ ] rocky road or
whatever I wanna see it all killer
eating a banana split sundae I didn't
want any more pictures okay here we go
all wrong way so then they have like Oh
bananas Joaquin River banana oh that
looks like the candy that nobody likes
oh yeah Oh what are those called I don't
know we called a Kenny nobody likes
personality yeah they'd always come in a
little pack then nobody wants them and
then here's I can decide oh so they
saying that one of them's like the main
attraction I would hire a pool filled a
sprinkle do you wanna know a jump in it
oh I want to go yeah wait what I'm sorry
start melting on sprinkles ah I think
they're fake sprinkles oh really
that's what's gonna happen to me really
stickiest [ __ ] yeah I'm not everything I
don't know I don't know it would be also
very hard to said I know I sound like a
downer but I just remember like the
article where they're talking about how
dirty the [ __ ] pit balls are in uh
yeah that is even harder to watch
they're so tiny so I just get a little
freaked out by that but it's pretty cool
though it's all your kids on that I know
but when you go in there that's all over
you do a little bit of urine don't hurt
you I'm not a little bit of turn space
got me very dirt won't hurt mm-hmm on
also made disease and disease kills
Museum it has ten exhibits and each room
has smells and tastes associated with
ice cream and like other desserts at the
end of the tour do you get to eat ice
cream yeah they do give you like there's
a look yeah
the entire exhibit where you can taste
certain things I like to come down and
so the admission is $29 for adult $18
for children and seniors and it includes
two curated ice creams tasting as well
as other shoes oh yeah go do that how
are they gonna be open until May 29th
let's do it let's do it I'm excited
I look at you I'm excited the only times
children I don't want to do it in ice
cream so this is like the the second one
that they're open right but the one in
New York it was like significantly
smaller I think was like four times
smaller than the one that is because
Ellie is always better than New York
Oh all right so for our last story I'm
gonna show you this video and it'll tell
you everything here we go
I like videos seven times that is
pushback highest therefore being vegan
or type boy okay
winters in Germany are cold and rain to
invite Germans to vacation in sunny
Mexico we mix the Mexican things they
love most
with the weather they hate most create
these to get one we used ultrasonic
humidifiers to vibrate the kilo at a
frequency that turned it indivisible
missed the tequila mist then condensed
into liquid form and drifters raindrops
that's crazy-making a real cloud rain
tequila every time it rained in Germany
oh my god is no kids
oh is that possible also sonic
vibrations David look at the winters
ever taste of Mexico I would say the
Mexico that's the real taste of Mexico
is a cloud and it has water and get
diary up you're just exactly a couple of
ringworms we want Germans to go to
Mexico to trying to collab don't go oh
yeah they're [ __ ] pale over there
they will get burn burn alive on anyway
this tequila cloud though is pretty
interesting the sex they're able to make
an entire cloud indoors and make it rain
every time it rains like a right pretty
that's pretty impressive
that's pretty cool yeah then like I
don't drink alcohol so I don't know and
I wish it rained crack just kidding what
Oliver on a crackhead from like [ __ ]
clouds like hailing crack oh boy do you
really want a Surenos tonight crack like
just pick something watermelon no it'll
hurt people
life's hard on slices oh it's like
watermelon once we go walk oh I wanna
see create a watermelon cloud babe yeah
the true names pour your cup I don't
know where if you would go where this is
where you go watermelon like Virginia or
some [ __ ] it's a hypothetical I kind of
like water water water
doesn't drink of all just drinkable
water keep it the same
for this specific type of installation
where it's indoors you create your cloud
what kind of coal kiss yeah but what is
that that is that a tourism for downtown
LA yeah so this is a tourism thing right
so whatever rains you're trying to pull
off you're gonna go how do you like this
smoking yeah yeah no in your house what
the [ __ ] you wanted to ring what about
how yeah thank you for you know know
what are those [ __ ] sentence these
online edible is a rhubarb or like you
know those [ __ ] oil sticks that
[ __ ] spread the all yeah yeah yeah
yeah those are specific karate the black
sovereign currently [ __ ] quit current
well you got a big everything hello yeah
give me that Cobra current and some
other there's a combination I like what
was it cause I don't know why I like
your super bill insider [ __ ] dude yo
what's up black Quran that's lower why
you would you want to read money that's
a good money would be green I'm like
little liquid money funny I mean more
money but smell wife I'm not any wise
drinking like Jesus doesn't know how to
follow the room yeah oh I said water Oh
water
eating was a drinking was Oh mint hard
because there's a lot of drinks unlike
what I'm thinking about right now
there's a dope drink that I could have
everyday it would have to be juice kind
of juice my tweet why he spoke up it's
the next one got three teams I got
sweetie white peach juice we please get
a lot that could drink that every day mi
u g ha does the thing that comes down
give us negative side effects no I don't
know yeah it was a great dog [ __ ]
fangs turn me out he's in his own world
for me I would want Arnold Palmer
Wow Windham is coffee would your honor
Plummer be like one drop is lemonade one
drop as ice here is it already done got
it what is it it's the Korean a great
drink sex act
oh I like sex I grew up on that so
but the thing that's good about it is it
has the great acid rain drop the brakes
yeah it's like the Japanese great - I
tried it right and that one thing gives
it that one with the can yeah it's a
small little village and they got the
hope that's a better and it tastes like
the Japanese grapes that you get
straight up in Italian cans got to be
[ __ ] so tiny I don't know but if I had
that rain all the time
Oh that'd be so great with the great
yeah it's about you to my eight of those
I know
okay well JK news fans I hope you guys
liked that video once again remember if
you want to be involved just submit some
articles in I'll suck your dick
now but seriously though there's more
videos up there
[Music]